the editor creator of the mm QB must
read stuff online back here on the show
how are you Peter
what bridge are you doing I am fine I
don't even know how you how do you keep
track of all this stuff it's
unbelievable I don't know it's crazy
three agencies over before it starts
but Joe Thomas adding some pep to the
festivities what do you think it is do
you think he's got a TV job lined up
Peter well obviously he did some
interviews at ESPN I know they were
considering him for part of the Monday
Night Football booth he's a really
really intelligent guy I don't know what
this is even though Joe has written some
columns for the mm QB and as a matter of
fact I reached out to him on Friday when
a lot of these rumors were starting and
saying hey would love you to write
something for us he was very
non-committal said he would think about
it and obviously he's thought about it
and he's walking away and it's strange
to say that you know I I think there's a
chance when it's over rich that if Joe
Thomas enters Canton one day he could
enter Canton as the player with the
lowest winning percentage of every of
anybody ever elected to the Pro Football
Hall of Fame I don't know that and I
have to check it but but I was thinking
about that today and so anyway he's been
a obviously a great great man well he
would also probably set the record for
most quarterbacks protected 20 and 11
years 22 zero
Wow different impacts he protected yeah
he would have if he played this year he
probably would have gotten to about 23
but so let's hit that right now Peter I
mean walk me through Cleveland and they
all the quarterback needy teams in the
draft pretty much went ahead and signed
a veteran for one year or when an
inquired one that's on the back end of a
deal
or or deal they can walk away from
Cleveland with Tyrod Taylor Denver with
Case Keenum
Jets with two different quarterbacks
Arizona with San Brad
do you think that that precludes any of
them from taking a quarterback in the
draft not at all as a matter of fact I
think I don't think necessarily Arizona
will but I do think most of the teams
you named I think Cleveland is taking a
quarterback in the top five I think it's
I think it is likely that the Jets are
going to take a quarterback up high and
I think it's I'm quizzical about Denver
because I do think that John Elway wants
to give Paxton Lynch one more chance but
how many times are you going to be able
to pick that high with a bunch of
prospects that you probably like more
than you liked Paxton Lynch the year he
came out I mean I keep hearing that you
know there's there's incredible love for
Baker Mayfield you know in Baker
Mayfield is going in the top ten either
to an existing team or somebody like
maybe Miami or Buffalo that will trade
up so I mean who knows but I do think
especially in the case of Cleveland I
mean Tyrod Taylor is a bridge
quarterback in the truest sense of the
word now could he play himself into a
role that is more than a bridge
quarterback absolutely it's all in his
hands but he would have to play I think
he would have to play great this year to
hold off whoever whoever there they're
going to pick in this draft as the
opening day starter 2019 Peter King
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
and everything that I saw and heard
about either online or from texts from
people around the league is that the
Jets were red-hot about losing Kirk
Cousins because they thought they had
him and then they acted like somebody
who just got sucked out on the river and
they were chasing and on tilt where they
just signed two quarterbacks what are
the Jets up to Peter I think basically
they remind me a little bit right now of
what John Elway is thinking in that
because I I mean obviously I think
there's a chance that the Broncos are
going to take one high two but they they
they have had a poor quarterback
situation for so long that they say we
are not going to get stuck again so one
of these guys one of these guys is going
to make it is going to help us survive
this year and you know obviously you
know McCown is a short-term solution but
McCown is extremely valuable in my
opinion because what pound does is
McCown is the most unselfish veteran
quarterback there is who's truly going
to help Bridgewater and whoever they
draft but the bottom line in this is
rich I don't think the Jets know right
now I think they have an idea of what
they'd like to do on draft day and
clearly I think that ID includes taking
a quarterback with their first-round
pick well and then the problem is is
getting that kid some reps with with
what you said and I think you're
absolutely right but I do think that
there is a little bit of the carson
palmer type thinking at play right now
with the Jets which is I still think
it's incredibly smart that that first
year is a redshirt year especially with
some of these quarterbacks and Arnold's
20 years old you know being a redshirt
in the first year I think it's still the
smartest thing that you can do and so in
my opinion that's my gut feeling as to
what the Jets are going to do take a
quarterback and let them learn from two
really good Lolo Joe guys
well then last one on this subject and
for the Jets to be so upset about losing
Kirk Cousins they had to have put a an
enticing deal on the table any idea what
cousins might have turned down from the
Jets to take the three fully eight I
don't know I don't know but I would be
surprised if it if it didn't average
thirty
because the Jets I'm sure that death
knew that even though they had Jeremy
Bates to offer and I'm sure that you
know if if Kirk Cousins is talking to
you know his old friend Kyle Shanahan or
Mike Shanahan they saying hey listen you
cannot go wrong going with Jeremy Bates
because that is the scheme and the
language and everything how you entered
the league in Washington and how you had
so much success so that had to be a big
part of this I mean that had to be a big
part of the Jets allure to him but at
the end of the day I you know you have
to compare the Jets in the Viking and
you have to think at least right now and
for the next year or two the Vikings are
gonna have a much better chance of going
to the promised land than the Jets are a
few minutes left here with Peter King in
the mmq be calm joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show okay so the 84 million
guaranteed from Kirk Cousins how does
that affect Aaron Rodgers and Matt
Ryan's future contracts best you can
tell Peter oh I mean you know they're
gonna be maybe the two or two of the
first 30 million-dollar quarterbacks in
history first 30 million-dollar players
in history I thought cousin I think
cousins could have been that head he
wanted to but what about the title a
guaranteed part here I mean that's new
that's completely unrelated to know what
I just honestly I just don't think it
matters and here's the reason why I
don't think it matters I want you to
answer this question honestly yep what
percentage chance is there that the
Minnesota Vikings by training camp 2020
are going to pardon the horn are going
to cut are gonna want to part ways with
Kirk Cousins what are the chances no I
know I know that I'm I'm just saying
though that that that there's others out
there I mean you saw Doug Baldwin's
tweet basically saying that this was a
watershed moment in the NFL and if I'm
Aaron Rodgers and I'm Matt Ryan even
though I'm in my 30s
I'm gonna say I Catic you fully
guaranteed contract why not me
or at least I understand but my whole
point about that is if you're the
Atlanta Falcons and you think that
you're gonna sign Matt Ryan you know it
is soon for the next three years four
fully guaranteed money is there any
reason why you think that Matt Ryan is
it going to be your guy barring a
catastrophic injury interesting there
isn't a reason and that's why look fully
guaranteed contracts are really
important for a guy like Doug Baldwin
they would have been important for a guy
like Richard Sherman but I don't I just
think quarterbacks are in a totally
differently because barring if you're an
established four thousand yard
quarterback there's you're not getting
cut in the next three years are you if
you have an eight year guarantee or
something like that that's different but
but I think this is a this is one of
those stories that really to me is not
all that significant I just thought it
was interesting for the first time that
we could compare pitching contracts
between quarterbacks and major figures
that seriously that area area 375 in
Philly in cousins three years eighty
four in Minnesota that actually just
happen yeah yeah you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right and to me
Cousins has a better chance to look good
in year three of the contract good one
last one for you is when I saw the sammy
watkins deal I the first person I
thought of and how it might affect
wasn't any wide receiver I thought of
loving on bail because bail had 85
catches last year and Watkins had 34 how
do you think I thought you have 39 how
do you think this affects what's going
on with levy on bail and Pittsburgh
everything that's played out from the
quarterback guaranteed dollars in the
wide receiver market and Jerick McKinnon
get in seven and a half per how do you
think that all works out here Peter you
know you still look at the running backs
in the NFL today rich and Le'Veon Bell
is gonna be guaranteed whatever the
number is you know 14 and a half million
whatever I mean
rich his cap number is five million
dollars more than any running back in
football and so I think that it would be
different if there was a super star
running back on the market
and he just Nate solders the crowd you
know he got he got 15 million a year or
whatever Soldier got but but there isn't
that thing I mean Jerick McKinnon is
hardly Le'Veon Bell in terms of wars or
you know franchise ability so my feeling
is I don't think jerk McKenith contract
means anything I don't think the
receiver contracts mean anything apples
to apples Le'Veon Bell is in a very very
tough spot because no running backs are
getting paid anywhere near what he wants
to get paid long-term I know but he's
not an apple he's an orange that's the
point I mean he's not an apple he's a
hell of an apple hey Peter I'm glad
you're safely negotiating the Apple
right now we heard that horn what was
that a boat was that what was that that
it was a cement mixer damn be careful
Peter
all right be in Columbus yeah big happy
new league gear to you sir thank you -
that's peter king @ SI underscore peter
king the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience